well I think the first thing to say is
the financial crisis was a really big
and very painful lesson for all of us I
think it's not just the money that had
to be put in taxpayers money to the
banks but also the crisis and the
recession that followed on average
probably meant that everyone in the UK
was about 20,000 pounds worse off than
they would have been so it's really
important that we've learned the lessons
and the system is safer I do think it's
safer I think it's simpler and I think
it's stronger than it was before the
crisis however there are three reasons
for that the reforms we put in have
tried to do a number of things first
we've stopped banks taking some of the
risky activities they were taking and
equally important made sure that they're
measuring properly they're scoring
properly the real risk they're taking
and managing that we do that through the
rules but also through a much more
intrusive supervision of the banks and
their operations and and next I think
banks have to take risks and those risks
will sometimes go wrong
banks will make losses but you have to
make sure that when they take those
losses they can absorb them without just
falling over and that's where Bank
capital is important the bank capital in
the system now is about ten times as
much as it was before the crisis and
it's not just the quantity of capital
it's the quality it has to be real money
basically shareholders funds that can
absorb losses when loans and other
things go wrong and we're sure the bank
can keep operating and keep providing
the sorts of services lending
transaction accounts that we all depend
on and finally it's not just capital
it's also liquidity because sometimes
the market dries out banks can no longer
borrow in the market and they have to be
able to withstand those periods of
market stress and carry on providing
services and banks in the UK and now
having about four times as much
liquidity about six hundred billion
pounds compared to what they had before
the crisis and the last thing I say is
banks will you know the bank may well
fail and then you have to ensure that if
a bank fails it can do so safely without
just cutting off the services it
provides
economy and it was because banks
couldn't fail safely without cutting off
those services that the taxpayer had to
step in during the crisis to save the
economy from the banks and we're putting
in place a regime that can ensure that
if a bank fails it can be wound down
safely and the losses can be borne by
the people who profit from the banking
good times and not my tax payer so for
those reasons I think the bank is the
banking system is safer and stronger
than it was you've mentioned that banks
aren't engaging in bad practices anymore
but yet we are seeing for example an
increase in things like interest free
credit periods being offered by credit
card lenders Vaman do you worry that
stresses are building up again in the
system it's one of the key reforms that
we made after the system was to give the
Bank of England the responsibility for
the stability of the financial systems a
whole its my direct responsibilities
deputy governor for financial stability
to ensure that we can scan and monitor
problems risk that might be building up
in the system exactly the sort of thing
that you mentioned and the financial
policy committee of the Bank of England
does that it does that four times a year
we publish our reports on risk twice
here we've taken action for example on
mortgages on bank capital before those
risk build-up to greatly another moment
we're looking very closely at this
question of consumer lending lending to
consumers some of the credit card
practices we've seen to see whether they
are a risk to the financial system and
whether action needs to be taken and
we'll be reporting on that at our next
meeting now you're older brussels hand
how much of a challenge is brexit going
to pose to the resilience of the banking
system our job is to make sure that the
resilience of the British banking system
is maintained regardless of of
developments that happen including the
outcome of the brexit negotiations and
the Berthier process and we're focused
very very closely on this we're
monitoring the plans of the financial
institutions in the UK their plans for
how they're going to deal with brexit
and we're also monitoring the plans of
all of the European Union firms that
operate
in the UK and in the City of London to
look at their plans for how they are
going to manage Brick City and if we
start to see financial stability risks
coming out of those plans the way they
think brexit will affect them they will
take action to monitor that and the
other point which comes back to
something you mentioned stress testing
the purpose of our annual stress test is
to subject the banking system to a very
very severe economic shop the sort of
thing that is not likely to happen but
could happen and to see that it's got
the capital and the ability the
resilience to withstand that shock keep
lending to the real economy keep
providing services and we've tested the
system against the number of scenarios
will continue to do there and that's one
way we'll be able to maintain resilience
regardless of outcomes